sometimes dudes minds are skewed and  they choose to go a killing cuz they saw  a Batman villain killing well ring a  bell  sometimes stars get armed guards when  they make a million bucks then call you  heartless mother bears do want the same  is it the fame polio and smallpox they  no longer kill it mass because the  vaccinations they are a thing of the  past  but you tell parents to skip them and  the science you contrast because just  like in your movie you're talking out  your ass it takes the talk and ass to  oppose a vaccination when your PhD is in  making funny faces takes to talk and has  to tell people they can't arm what you  don't walk around without an armed  bodyguard it takes a talk and ass to  cope phantom and demented when you are  the one who or something uninvented  takes a talk in ass to be out there pass  and blame  you shot someone on every TV ever made  takes a talking  [Music]